Thursday the Latin Grammy awards are
right back here in Las Vegas sure our
23rd year for the show and there's some
big names lined up Christina Aguilera
Mark Anthony John Legend I mean do you
need any more yeah Candice Charles
joining us live this morning at Michelob
Ultra arena with a backstage sneak peek
of all the swag and the fun and uh what
do you have on there is that is that
logoed material for the event and Miss
Candace
it sure is Heather you got that
absolutely right good morning folks this
is just one of the many items here and
the talent gift Lounge that some of the
folks can come through and get this is
from the Bacardi Booth but there's so
much more here to enjoy we're going to
give you a little bit of tour here and I
got Eliza Monet Morales with me thank
you so much for joining me again this
morning you're going to be here all week
with these folks helping people pick
things out tell us where we're at
exactly indeed to in addition to
enjoying a cocktail by Bacardi as you
notice they'll also be in a limited
edition jean jacket we also noticed that
Libations people are a little bit
nervous in between rehearsals absolutely
to definitely set a mood and so Frontera
wines is back with us they were a big
hit during the Grammys so they're back
this year as well too everybody loves a
little red ones have some red wine and
then you can even pair it up with a
Spotify playlist that they curated for
the show now as I mentioned before one
of the big hits has been from people
Latino to providing us with the ultimate
accessory to wear on the red carpet so
they've actually partnered with Mariah
1998 for these faux fur bags
right and then you'll see that there is
a little uh wallet inside and it's by
the brand waste tea and what I love
about it is that it's tea leather which
I had never even heard about and so then
that's actually been really cool and
then there's a pin that says no fur so
if people want to rock that on whatever
they're wearing to support Peter Latino
then we're all for it so it's all about
supporting the family here right before
we get to this one yeah I'm gonna do a
little tease for it because I know we
gotta wrap it up a little bit soon this
is an old classic I know you guys can
look look at it really quickly we're
going to be talking about it coming up
in the next segment so you'll want to
hear what's so special about this thank
you so much Liza I appreciate you all of
this good times are going to be over the
next three days of course the Latin
Grammys kicks off on Thursday at five if
you want tickets you can still get them
but you guys pay 600 so if you don't
want to do that you can watch it on
Univision of course we have you covered
with all the details on our website
newsnow.com for now live from The
Mandalay Bay where the Latin Grammys
will be this Thursday I'm Candace
Charles 8 news now all right Candice he
needs about 600 bucks if you want to go
to the Grammys and if you want to
actually see those gift bags you have to
be nominated oh yeah oh yeah you're not
gonna see though that's why we're
showing you the gift bags now